huge news story
the liver King
has been exposed as a fraud do you know
who the liver King is I didn't either
Brett Cooper actually turned me on to
him he's some social media phenomenon
where he's a super jacked guy who never
has a shirt on and he's always just
eating
organs of giant animals he'll sit there
I saw one video he said why would you
chew gum when you could eat lung and he
pulls off part of a cow lung and starts
chewing on it the whole idea was I don't
really do anything special I just eat
all these totally Primal kinds of foods
and that's how I got super jacked and
the guy was obviously on steroids and it
just came out that he's on steroids and
here's his apology
I'm making this video to apologize
because I [ __ ] up
because I'm embarrassed and ashamed
because I lied and I misled a lot of
people
I've stated that this is a complicated
Topic at least to me it is because
before social media I was rich and
Anonymous and after social media I'm
still rich but no longer Anonymous and I
never expected this kind of exposure in
the public eye
it's been tricky as [ __ ] to navigate
well
clearly I did it wrong and I'm here now
to set the record straight
yes I've done steroids and yes I am on
steroids monitored and managed by
trained hormone clinician
wow shocking none of us could ever see
this
no you can't
you can if you're not taken by this
constant push that is accelerated by
social media and by our pop culture and
our celebrity culture to just be more
and more outrageous more and more
shocking one Maxim that I often come
back to on this show is hey be normal
just be normal it's good to be normal
and so we're talking about at the top of
the show you don't have to hand it to
Hitler you don't actually you don't uh
the people are titillated by really
shocking statements and and it gets in
shocking images and it gets people to
think wow maybe this thing that I know
is not possible or not true or
completely out of left field maybe it
really is true
usually it's not
usually things are are just a lot more
normal than all of that if generally
speaking you can just trust your
faculties of reason and your moral
conscience and the traditions in which
you have been raised generally speaking
those are going to be much better guides
to uh to your own life than you know
some some person making some insane sort
of claim whether it be about uh you know
the second world war or about uh how to
get really jacked eating cow long or
something uh if if it's
if it seems too wild crazy singular to
be true it it probably is
this is in part why we are conservatives
because we understand that the old tried
and true stuff has a much better track
record than the modern Flights of Fancy
titillating though they may be hi
Michael Irwin here I am an
astrophysicist which I mentioned for
context because you recently piqued my
curiosity when you mentioned that behind
the heliocentrism debate within the
Catholic Church during the 17th century
were deeper and more profound
philosophical and Theological issues I
was wondering if you could talk from
your perspective as a Catholic Christian
about what those philosophical issues
are and maybe also about what are the
philosophical and perhaps even
metaphysical implications of the
einsteinian view of the universe in
which there is no preferred Center to
the universe
thank you as always for your wisdom
a rune very very good question yes you
can see uh how misrepresented the
Catholic Church's position on science
has been when you look at the history of
these sorts of controversies one uh the
most prominent scientists ever have been
not only Catholic but in many cases have
been Catholic priests
father George lametris is the person who
first theorized the Big Bang
Catholic priest Gregor Mandel Catholic
priest the discoverer of mendelian
inheritance and genetics
a Copernicus was maybe a Catholic priest
though he that's a little bit unclear he
was at least a Catholic Canon
and many many others but but if you look
at say when Copernicus puts forward the
idea that the Earth revolves around the
Sun
he was not really persecuted for it uh
Galileo puts forward this idea and he he
was persecuted for it but not exactly
for for suggesting the idea it was more
for being just a huge jerk all the time
and and so when copernicus's book comes
out on the celestial spheres he there
there was a preface added to the book
that said that this is meant to
facilitate calculations but it's not
necessarily meant to be taken literally
Galileo comes out and not only proposes
his view as a literal view but he also
antagonizes the pope and members of the
clergy in the book and he has
simplicious in this dialogue meaning
simpleton though it's a reference to a
an interpreter and a commentator on
Aristotle but it's obviously meant to
suggest that this person is a simpleton
and that represents the Pope's view so
he just was kind of a jerk and he didn't
play his cards really straight either
the reason I bring up the word literal
is because
the word literal is very confusing
especially in our day and age because
literal is supposed to mean not
figurative or not symbolic but literal
refers to letters which are signs and in
our day and age are symbols as well uh
so what does it even mean to to be
literal if you tell me
you mentioned Einstein's view of the
universe when you tell me that there is
no Center to the universe or we're in
this kind of static you know infinite
sort of universe or any really any
modern scientific depiction of the
universe that you want and you tell me
that the Earth is on this little ball
circling this other little ball in a in
a galaxy in a in a galaxy cluster and
another galaxy cluster and Galaxy
supercluster
I don't know what that means
if you tell me that man is the center of
the universe
I I do know what that means
and furthermore when you say man is the
center of the universe that more
accurately describes man's actual
position in the world because man is the
Nexus of the physical world and the
metaphysical world through his rational
soul man is the only being in this world
that that can be said of
animals are bodies and they have a soul
proper to their nature but they don't
have a rational Soul that's why we don't
put them on trial when a when a cat
scratches a human being we don't
prosecute the cat ideas are meaningful
and they they have consequences in the
world but they don't have bodies
Angels and Demons which I happen to
believe exist as have most people
throughout all of human history but some
doubt it today but Angels and Demons
are real they have metaphysical reality
but they don't they don't have bodies
only in man do you see that Nexus
perfectly in the Incarnation and in the
Blessed Sacrament so that
that
representation more accurately describes
what is really going on in reality even
even if in order to make calculations we
accept the the premise that the Earth
revolves around the Sun and the sun is
in the Galaxy or whatever
that's fine but that is a representation
too that's just a picture in your head
so that you can make models and make
certain calculations this is a point
that is really driven home by Owen
Barfield who you'll hear a lot of us on
daily wire bring up this writer a lot
he's the guy who was instrumental in
converting CS Lewis to Christianity
really really brilliant philosopher and
he just points out that in in the world
what what we take in
uh about the world around us
is necessarily just representations
right I'm not I'm not really seeing the
camera as the camera I'm
taking in the the information that the
camera has in itself and then I am
perceiving that and then I'm creating a
concept of that in my mind and we hope
that that Accords as well as it can to
reality but it is a distinct thing and
what modern science does is it it
separates the the
representations it separates the
phenomena from what the phenomena really
mean and it creates a sort of idolatry
out of that so that's why we think of
the human body now as just a bag of
chemicals
we don't think of it as a meaningful
thing with a soul because that's the way
science has to treat the body we think
of of therefore the cosmos in that same
way but there is more to the cosmos than
than just the physical world there's the
metaphysical world as well we all know
that we have to know that we have to
accept that that's the only way that we
can talk that's the only way that our
ideas can have meaning that's the only
way we can have hopes and joys and loves
uh and and all the rest of the things
that we can't quite touch
so that's
a long-winded version of that view and
it's it's why it's kind of like that
bell curve you know for for IQ it's like
a really dumb guy would say I heard the
man's the center of the universe heard
that they're and then the guy in the
middle would say well actually you know
the Earth is in this galaxy you're in
the super claw store and I don't know
man and then you get to the top of the
bell curve and it's just the sort of
Jedi Knight is saying actually man
really is the center of the universe
that's that's I think what's going on
when we talk about our representations
of science make sure you head on over to
the member block we also have fake
headlines I need your help in in
Discerning which headlines are real so
if you are not a member click the link
in that description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]